my name is you Jule ooh I walk on front
end 3d graphics so today I'm going to
give a overview of 330 graphics in front
end and also talk about some new stuff
what are we working on currently and as
you know we have a very rich set of 3d
primitive directives and the options
these are the best components for all 3d
visualization functions and these in
blue are newly introduced leader in
version 10 and we will keep add to it
but today I'm going to let you take a
little bit closer look under see what's
behind the sea for 3d graphics we have
for rendering engines and I'm going to
use this example to see to compare
between them they are depth buffer depth
peeling and the BSP tree and software
depth buffer is a is a default method I
used for non transparent object
rendering it is using the as the name
choose it is using a depth buffer for
depth computing because it's using the
hardware it would be very fast and use
less more less memory it is available it
is always available but the downside is
it might have some Z fighting issues
like over here so then what is Z
fighting it is caused by the depths
precision when are assuming there are
two coplanar polygons there
we need to do a pixel r44 that speed
depth computing for each pixel because
of the computing error some of the
pixels we are on top of the other
service others are are not and that
caused the Safari issue if if you
improve the precision of the depth
buffer from 24 bit to 32 bit which is
supported on some of the new hardware's
it might improve it a little bit but
cannot totally remove that because it
come with the depth buffer so the good
solution to that is trying to avoid the
co-planner by adding a small offset to
it so let's talk about the dep spilling
it is also using the depth buffer what I
did what the difference is it is a
multiple rendering path measured because
of the transparency because using the
depth buffer it's fast it's use less
memory it will be available on most
hardware's and drivers but my not on
some very older computers because it's
using depth buffer we also have the sea
fighting issue here BSP tree is a
different method it split or 3d polygons
into very small suburb triangles and try
to sort them before Randy it because of
the splitting it will take a lot of
memory compare the depth buffer and
because of the tree BSP tree can
stretching on and also the sorting it
will be slow but it is available at the
time
it will not have the g fighting shoes
but it has its own artifacts on the mesh
lining we are look very dashed why these
artifacts coming from it is also because
of the precision to their computer
arrows I mentioned that line polygons we
are subdivided and the lines will be
divided into sub lines as well so they
are supposed to be on the top of service
should be coplanar with surface but
because of computing arrows some of the
sub lines were on top of it some of them
were not that is why it is look dashed
you might also have some stinking issues
because of a splitting but the main
issue is the memory in my cause crash in
some cases software it is also using BSP
tree what it is different is it work
project or 3d objects into 2d object and
the jaw or the 2d object so because it's
also using BSP tree to where you have
all the down side from BSP tree and
other than that because of the
projection it will be even slower and
because of it is using 2d join layer it
might have some features not supported I
like texture in this case the texture is
not chewing up
but it is good to know the downside for
each rendering engine so so you can
choose the right one if you have
different needs so you might want to ask
why we still need a software case well
they must some cases like the driver or
the hardware doesn't would work very
well and if this happens the software
work can be a choice and about the
depths pili availability there are some
flag in the system information can check
and it is if it is says here to it yeah
it means def spinning spotty them so by
default the depth pinion depth buffer
will be used ok so color buffer and
depth buffer color buffer is usually
what you see as a random result it
contains the color value for each pixel
Rendon and the depth buffer as I
mentioned before it useful for depth
computing but you can also choose to
visualize that like in this example or
if you rotated the view the view point
changes the depth value changes as well
um so let's think about there's the
example let's say there the object is
there the camera is there it is looking
in this direction the these lives go
into the object you are first hit the
first layer of the object and then the
second and then the third and you can
choose to visualize these different
layers with these different layers you
can have a better understanding about
the what structure it is and if you can
buy those different layer together in
order you might you can get a very good
transparent result
that is how deaf spilling works
Precision's about the color buffer
there's four choice you can choose right
now 8-bit is is usually used by D for
the form primitives except the rest 3d
but you can also choose the high bids
for you need here's the example I don't
know you can see clearly here the I said
the voxel value to a very small color
and it is not received a very well in
the head bit but the works were in other
high bids there's another example you
might see it better if I I can try to
change it to a even swamp lower value
and you are see are even for hi beads
they are some different there so
heartbeats means more precision ok now
I'm talk about some new stuff whether we
are working on from time to time I got
users come to me and complain that
assuming we have a very large data set
we know it is static it does not contain
any dynamics in it is there any way to
optimize it at least to make it
responding to 22 interactions now we
have the method option you can optimize
it what it does is just trying because
it knows that it is static data so it
what it does it try to reuse the data
and hardware instead of keep pushing
data to the hardware and through the way
then I want to show you
a data set this is from a user the data
set is rasam powder from the real world
data but the steer it contains half a
million polygons there so this is with
other the options setting and you are
see it is not really responding you can
see the familiar is just about to I'm
sure you are not satisfied with that so
but how about tried the up the option
for the first time loading it will take
almost sim same time but but once it is
loaded it can random much faster because
it can reuse the data you can see if
frame rate goes up to 35 36 so it is
almost 20 times faster are
okay I won't talk about some another
issue like assuming we are going to make
a very nice camera fights for animation
light like the google map google earth
does and so you have a very decent 3d
models you have a very large texture it
contains all the details so that when
you look closer it shows up very good
but in some view angle it looks very bad
it has adverse why this happens is
because the Texas is big they are exist
some cases like when doing the texture
mapping it will map the whole area into
just one pixel but the hardware can only
do one Texas sampling that is why the
artifacts coming from the solution is to
use the map how it works it just
automatically generally when you win the
application push the data to the
hardware it will automatically genuine a
set of downsize the duplicator of the
domain texture so the hardware can
choose the right texture to look at
based on the viewpoint if and to avoid
the multiple 22 mapping multiple texts
into one pixel I want to show you the
example here it is a Contessa texture of
this texture size itself is 110 megabyte
it is it is huge and them for each year
channel you can test it bit you are you
I take about 30 seconds to to come up
most time to spend on let me do some
multitasking and save some time
I'm going to try to compare the version
with mid map and the resolve me back
let's see if that pops up not yet here
we go try to evaluate this one we will
see here here are there are a lot of
anything artifacts there and if
oops
they were coming yeah let's compare them
side-by-side there's no you mean the mid
map and without my bap there's actually
they are the commands that they are
totally added identical what's what's
the difference internally I turned their
mid map on and off that it's by some
some some open gia implementation yeah
this is another release day yes yeah it
is turn down a but yeah yeah but if you
want the option we can add an option for
that to turn around turn it off so you
can have a better idea I can try but
this I if you assume that you will
become the lard become larger you won't
have the multiple mapping multiple texts
into one pixel case so it would be
different case last I want to talk about
the lighting on rest of 3d lighting our
rest sweetie isn't easy because it's a
little bit Russell sweetie is a little
bit different it does not contain any
geometry information like a polygons and
the normals so to make the work you need
to compute normals for each voxel by the
color gradient values and also to the
computing for each voxel to the light in
computing for each voxel with the with
this option you can have their three
different choices it is by default is
turned it off but you can turn it on
what the difference between true and
enhanced age this option
we r do extra work I try to remove some
of the background noise and trying to
enhance the key features by multiply the
alpha channel with with the magnitude of
the normal computed the gradient values
here's a comparison here a USC without
lighting you wouldn't see much details
with the but with with with lighting on
you can get a much better at that depth
perception I want to try a different
color function this one is used as a
default color function for image of 3d I
want to show you the difference between
the normal lighting and I can also
change it specularity so here some of
the noise is removed and like the part
of neck you can visualize more details
rotated yeah you can also zoom me so
let's the yeah you can paint now ya hear
yeah this is a value this is a useful
for the default for for for me 2 3 d it
is included in the Seco de but you can
also make yourself here's the example
this is a explicitly there were and with
the same data set that you can choose to
visualize the internal structure and the
US with the depth perception there are
more details instead of instead of just
flat and and you can zoom in and
considering that the job it is doing 45
46 frame rate is pretty good
and can you do exactly that on the first
one
this was a little bit of art art like
style but in some cases will look flat
we implemented the lighting for all
cases so it will work any combinations
here's the example of spotlighting and
point lighting bunch of point 19 so so
anything work with polygons we are work
with registry now so yeah that's my talk